das geht ja jetzt schon echt ein
bisschen nervös muss ich sagen es geht
heute nämlich nicht um wenig muss man
ganz ehrlich auch einfach mal so
festhalten
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich befinde mich
gerade in meinem büro und hier kamen vor
ungefähr zwei stunden fünf pakete an ich
hab es ja schon öfter mal angekündigt
und viele von euch haben auch sehr
darauf gewartet dass sich auf jeden fall
auch noch mal bei saturn bestellen werde
diesmal dann für 3000 euro
also wir haben heute wirklich die
teuerste wundertüte mystery box die man
es auch immer nennen möchte die je im
deutschsprachigen youtube bereich
ausgepackt wurde
ich glaube der vorwand ja diemer und
drop die haben für 2000 euro bestellt
ich denke mal dass bei denen auch krasse
sachen trotzdem drin gewesen sind weil
das war ja vor weihnachten irgendwie
alles ein bisschen lukrativer trotzdem
habe ich jetzt einmal 3000 euro bezahlt
warenwert soll 6000 euro sein und ja ich
bin gespannt läutet man muss sagen eine
sache die kann ich euch jetzt schon
verraten weil das habe ich direkt
gesehen hier ist ein dyson hot and cool
das ist das ein luftreiniger oder wir
sind auf jeden fall sehr gefragt aktuell
den haben wir halt einfach so mit
geschick kostet ungefähr 60 euro ich bin
euch die preise hier mal einige kennt
das ganze und dann machen wir uns jetzt
gleich mal an die anderen pakete aber
eine sache wollte ich noch loswerden
wenn dieses video
ich hab das schon ewig nicht mehr
gemacht deswegen dazu bekommen wenn wir
20.000 likes auf diesem video schaffen
dann bestelle ich das nächste mal für
10.000 mache ich ruhig ich schwöre ich
mach das ehrlich ich hab das jetzt immer
gesagt ich hab's noch immer gemacht
deswegen leute ich bin gespannt es macht
mir unfassbar viel spaß und wir haben
wir so
paket da bin ich eigentlich angespannten
drauf hier sind nämlich denke ich
relativ viele kleine sachen drin auch
vielleicht handys zum einen kann man ja
erwarten heute die pakete die darstellen
sind ziemlich schwer da ist glaube ich
zweimal das gleiche drin irgendwas für
die küche oder so egal wir fangen jetzt
an ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß aber
jetzt super g in den kanal würde ich
mich sehr freuen
letztlich würde sagen wir sind mal mit
dem geist der china bot und cool ja ich
habe mir nämlich tatsächlich auch mal
gedacht ich brauche unbedingt für meine
wohnung an sich finde ich dass unnötig
aber es sieht schon stylish ausnahme
dass dinge ist auch wirklich ziemlich
groß doch mal ja gut also ich könnte
jetzt auspacken oder halt nicht
ihr seht ja wie es aussieht und
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch
haben so ein ding auch schon mal im
einsatz gesehen
deswegen lasse ich den anfang macht
morgen original verpackter drin und wir
kommen jetzt zu den anderen paketen auf
die ich ultrabook ich bin echt gespannt
man hier auf jeden fall dabei im jahr
reist du das ringt und leute ganz
wichtig für die das jetzt hier zum
ersten mal schauen
ich nehme immer den günstigsten preis
der nicht irgendwo im internet finde für
ein gleichwertiges produkt also dann
würde ich sagen wir mal hier mit weiter
also das ding ist auf jeden fall wird er
schwer
kitchenaid küchenhilfe irgendwie
vielleicht so im thermomix oder so und
was ich glaube ist dass ich dennoch mal
ab in dem anderen paket weil wir sind
eigentlich gleich aus
was ist das denn so sieht das ganze aus
kitchenaid wir haben hier den 4,8 liter
diesel
sorry wenn ich jetzt wieder hinbekomme
dass ich mich mit irgendwas nicht
ausgehen aber damit kenne ich mich jetzt
wirklich nicht aus ich kann euch hier
den preis ein bin ich schaue es jetzt
nach ich habe keine ahnung ob das 200
euro sinne überhaupt aus acht höhere
sind es kann also bei küchengerät das
kann auch schon teuer sein was kann denn
das ding mal ist also es ist ein
multifunktionales gerät wie gut ich
finde jetzt hier für 49 90 bis 5 109 90
euro gut sagen war 400 euro kostet das
ding an sich ganz nice ich habe davon
zwei stück ganz ehrlich das lohnt sich
auch nicht denn auch zu machen sowas
keine ahnung da nehme ich lieber gleich
der andere boxer genauer unter die lupe
gehofft nicht verheimlicht oder so
kommen wir zu diesem paket
ich glaube aber da ist das gleiche drin
wird es trotzdem kurz ab vielleicht
einer anderen farbe blau
ihr seht schon alle dasselbe gericht
mache ich das so schnell wie dazu ist ja
langweilig also die dinger können wir
pro gerät 100 euro berechnet
800 euro insgesamt plus dieses styling
sind was schon bei 1314 circa so also da
muss eigentlich noch was kommt dann
musste ich kurz kommen weil da muss ich
auch sagen wenn das ganze ein flop wird
dann bestelle ich ja nicht wieder für 10
k
das wäre selbstmord wir haben jetzt ein
etwas kleineres paket was auch nicht
ganz so schwer ist ich denke aber da
sind mehrere sachen habe ich ja schon
gesagt und ich hoffe hier drin sitzt
jetzt richtig wert also muss eigentlich
weil sonst wäre ich enttäuscht und wir
legt man sich noch meilenweit von den
6000 euro entfernt hahaha
wir haben hier eine sony ericsson 100
sony keine marke ich nehme gerade auch
mit nach sony auf das ist die sony alpha
6 500 hier haben wir eine etwas kleinere
kamera trotzdem ist sein und statt ok
vietoris die ich weiß noch nicht wie es
euch hier einig das ist auf jeden fall
sehr geil ich sehe es gerade hier
zwischen okay die es gebraucht also die
ersten preise die mine gerade im
springen sind zwischen 800 und 900 euro
ich weiß nicht also ich denke das gibt
es auch noch günstiger trotzdem ihr seht
hier zum preis den günstigsten preis den
ich sonst auch gefunden habt machen wir
weiter mit mit diesem gerät was haben
wir denn hier noch eine eine panasonic
lumix dmc tz10 und ich glaube das
gleiche haben jedoch nicht zweites mal
ich glaube die wussten dass das paket an
einem youtuber rausgeht anschein weil
ich habe oft überlegt brauchen wir
wieder eine neue kamera
ihr könnt ihr in die kommentare
schreiben findet ihr das bild ok oder
muss ich mal hin was neues investieren
trotzdem an sich kann ich mit diesem
kleinen kamera ist nicht so viel
anfangen
aber vielleicht hat jemand anderes und
mal gucken was mach ich mal auf du
interessierst dich an sich wirklich ein
sehr kompaktes cooles gerät 4 k das ding
hat auf jeden fall power so klein
hebräischen kann ich meinen eltern geben
wenn sie irgendwie tourismus reisen
machen das ist so eine richtige turi
kamera vor der ich doch mal vor diesen
touren macht so damit damit dass du aus
geradezu den turm entpacken schnell mal
wieder ein
was haben wir hier ein objektiv oder 6 x
20 mm f 1.4 gut hier also ich hätte
jetzt niemals
was da so viel kamera equipment brehm
ist ich bin wirklich bis jetzt sehr sehr
leid also das ist ein nettes das ist ein
wirklicher das objektiv und ich bin mir
auch sicher dass dinge ist teuer
das kann ich sogar mein gott vielleicht
gestört
vielleicht behalte ist das junge ich
muss sofort abtreten das ist vielleicht
wirklich bin
ich bin richtig euro mobilisiert gerade
vorhin das kann ich auch meine songs
drauf haben ok neu kostet das ding 900
euro trotzdem natürlich nicht schlecht
allerdings erst wenn ich auf jeden fall
top zufrieden gute ausbeute
weiter geht's wir haben hier noch etwas
ganz besonderes und zwar ein acer laptop
ich glaube es ist ein mindest mal
gespannt was wir hier viel modell haben
machen wir das ganze mal auf ich sag's
trifft drei hier haben wir welche für
700 bis 1000 100 euro ja also da kann
man sich auch nicht mehr das was
allerdings aus der box ich hoffe mal
dabei ist nichts mehr drin sind ich muss
dann noch kurz was zu ergänzen nur hatte
ich mal kurz hin da dringen heißt was 53
das genaue modell sf3 13 52 78 71 mit
1024 gb speicher und 8 gigabyte
arbeitsspeicher intel core i7 prozessor
winterszenen ja gut deswegen ist er auch
gar nicht mal so genau hier leute eine
sache haben wir noch und da bin ich
jetzt mal ganz gespannt weil dieses ding
habe ich noch nie gesehen es ist auch
nicht groß das ist der ex die bordcrew
930 ich muss sagen ich muss sagen habe
schon 800 lkw zu lang arbeitet die
staubsauger sind sehr geil ich habe mir
selber auf einem büro stellen das hier
ist jetzt eine mischung aus
handstaubsauger und sarp roboter so weit
ich weiß würde ich sagen checken wir das
ganze doch mal aus auf jeden fall schon
mal den saugroboter ich muss nicht mal
dass es so ein ding gibt was einen
handstaubsauger integriert hat
august rechts oder wie genau er kümmert
da kommen wir doch bekannt vor aber das
kommt hier oben drauf auf diese
handstaubsauger warum wir da noch so
einfach so das ist sonst hätte das war
okay ich versteh ich bleibe euch hier
ein foto ein oder vielleicht video wenn
ich irgendwo ins finde das ist sonst da
hast du alles in einem also die roboter
dockingstation plus ja ihr seht ihr
wahrscheinlich an sich demuth idee finde
ich habe allerdings zuhause bot hier im
büro auch deswegen brauche ich so was
eigentlich nicht und jetzt auch noch mal
der preis dafür
ich setze mich jetzt immerhin rechne
alles zusammen und wir sehen uns sofort
wieder ich bin so gespannt
bis gleich okay leute ich auf alles
zusammenrechnet erst live für euch ich
weiß es noch nicht wir rechnen zusammen
let's go crazy riebe rechne 600 plus 400
plus 400 plus 750 + 400 plus 400 plus
899 plus 900 + 390 5000 148 euro
ja was soll ich sagen sollte kann man
auf jeden fall mit arbeiten ich hätte
gedacht dass wir noch mehr
ich habe jetzt wirklich immer den
günstigsten preis genommen aber karmann
vormachen wenn ihr euch für das eine
oder andere interessiert wie immer lucky
donkey punkte in meinem job da wird das
ganze weiter verkauft könnt ihr dort
gerne mal vorbeischauen und ich hab mir
gedacht für alle nachwuchs youtuber von
euch diese panasonic dmc fz100 ein hallo
sich schreibt einfach in die kommentare
und dann hast du in seinem namen in die
kommentare zu schreiben ganz wichtig und
nötig das ganze auf dann 27 hoffentlich
jemand darüber abonniert sehr gerne den
kanal
ich kann das video mit einem lachen
beenden
und dank fürs zuschauen leute hart rein